[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
oui cette inflation un impact sur le
panier de la ménagère et sur le coup de
vie en général
de toute manière générale on essaie de
faire attention aussi donc en priorise
effectivement tout ce qui est nécessaire
et tout ce qui est superflu on fait plus
attention on continue d'en faire mais je
pense qu'on peut établir son budget
raisonnablement
par exemple je suis pas super marché on
va plutôt du dans les rayons directs
avec la liste de courses ce qui évite de
d'être tenté par des choses
superficielles
je pense qu'il faudrait peut-être que
les gens réapprennent à vivre d'une
manière différente surtout ça je crois
qu'il faut qu'il faut changer ses
habitudes moi j'ai arrêté de prendre ma
voiture par exemple et la piscine elle
est à
une demi-heure de marche avant j'y
allais en voiture mais maintenant je
vais à pied
l'inflation est là la tête des
conséquences sur les positions de du
prêteur et de l'emprator bien évidemment
parce que dans un premier temps
lorsqu'il y a de l'inflation la hausse
des prix va se propager au taux
d'intérêt quand on remonte un premier
taux d'intérêt un taux directeur ça
signifie qu'on remonte le premier taux
le taux le plus bas qui est fait aux
banques et ça signifie que la banque va
comme les hypermarchés répercuter les
hausses de prix les hausses de couple et
donc le taux d'intérêt que vous paierez
sera lui aussi non seulement plus élevé
mais plus plus fort que les taux
directeurs bien évidemment donc ce que
je veux dire ici c'est lorsque les taux
d'intérêt augmentent sous effet
d'inflation toute chose étant égale par
ailleurs sans considérer d'autres
éléments on s'aperçoit que a priori ça
fait le bonheur du prêteur puisque c'est
sa rémunération la rémunération de son
prêt qui est impacté qui est
avantageusement impacté et
symétriquement ça fait bien évidemment
la peine de l'emprunteur qui lui voit le
coût de son emprunt s'alourdir
si on regarde un peu plus loin
l'inflation produit aussi parce que en
matière de d'emprunt il y a capitale et
intérêt là on a regardé l'intérêt la
rémunération il y a le capital
l'inflation va proposer là encore va
provoquer une érosion du capital mais
cette fois-ci les prêteurs les
emprunteurs ne sont plus dans les mêmes
positions en érodant le capital emprunté
ça fait le bonheur du de l'emprunteur
puisqu'il va voir moins à remboursé
qu'il a emprunté ça fait le drame du
prêteur qui lui se voit finalement un
peu pénalisé par la situation puisque
son capital va fondre sous effet de
l'inflation l'emprunteur doit encore
regarder les conditions de son emprunt
les conditions le contrat les contrats
peuvent être fait à taux fixes ou à taux
variables alors simplement c'est pas une
recommandation ici simplement c'est
selon ce que l'individu en question
imagine de l'avenir parce que je le
disais précédemment on raisonne
aujourd'hui on prend la décision
aujourd'hui mais on intègre le futur on
l'apprend on imagine en demain c'est une
forme d'actualisation et bien il doit se
positionner sur les taux d'intérêt fixes
s'il estime qu'ils sont suffisamment bas
et qu'ils ne peuvent qu'augmenter demain
il va à l'inverse choisir des contrats
avec des taux variables s'il pense que
les taux sortent d'une période de
surchauffe et qu'il ne peuvent que
baisser demain et pour profiter de cette
baisse il choisira les taux variables
s'agissant de l'épargne pour les ménages
qui peuvent réaliser une épargne et je
le rappelle c'est plutôt ça concerne
plutôt les classes moyennes et
supérieures entre guillemets et bien on
peut considérer que l'épargne est un peu
comme une roue de secours parce que
mettre de l'argent de côté comme dit le
bon sens populaire c'est pas
complètement décalé et c'est pas
complètement étranger d'économie puisque
ça signifie bien pensez à l'avenir et
laisser la possibilité à l'avenir de
désépargner c'est-à-dire d'aller puiser
dans cette épargne lorsque demain votre
revenu ne sera plus suffisant il
semblerait que l'épargne a été remplie
que les Français ont rempli leur
Madeleine au maximum et maintenant il
commence déjà à puiser dans leur épargne
pour satisfaire leurs besoins de
consommation courante plus précisément
les ménages interrogés sur la période
récente ce sont dit majoritairement
plutôt pessimistes quant à l'évolution
du niveau de vie en France et dans une
moindre mesure ils sont aussi pas très
optimistes même plutôt pessimiste quant
à l'évolution de leur situation
financière personnelle quand on essaie
de voir pourquoi quand l'Insee pose des
questions un peu plus en détail
voyez-vous une opportunité à faire une
grosse dépense parce qu'on sait que ça
peut marquer des étapes dans la vie d'un
ménage pensez-vous nécessaire et
opportuns d'épargner là la tendance est
plutôt de dire plus maintenant donc il y
a une tendance à Revin normand une
tendance à la baisse qui fait coup un
peu à ce qu'on disait précédemment en
parlant de cet amorce de désépargne on
épargne moins parce que justement on va
puiser dans son épargne et puis il y a
un indicateur un point encore important
signifiant concernant l'inflation les
anticipations d'inflation des ménages
sont positives retourne et son positives
et quand on regarde les graphiques sur
périodes un peu plus longues on voit que
ce full cas en 1982 et en 2022 on y
reviendra c'est là c'est un peu le fait
des politiques de relance des
gouvernements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]